[musique]
Aujourd'hui, nous regardons le cimetière de l'Alliance
Romain, premier siècle après JC, nous obtenons aujourd'hui
Sur environ 46 tombes, nous attendons des extensions
Environ 75 à 80 tombes reçoivent des missions chez nous
[musique]
C'est la première fois que nous voyons un cimetière complet de l'époque
Les Romains sont à Gaza, et ceci est la preuve que je suis à Gaza.
Il existe une voie romaine connue depuis l'Antiquité
Le Romain est la route qui mène à la mosquée
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes tombés au cimetière, je veux dire, si Dieu le veut
Que Dieu nous conduise au chemin si nous atteignons le chemin
Roman veut dire que c'est quelque chose d'important scientifiquement
[musique]
La vieille ville de Gaza n'a pas besoin d'argent
Pas de fouille, pas de protection, pas de restauration, et puis ça
Le projet signifie que nous l'avons
Moyens pris en charge jusqu'à la fin de la recherche
Et documentation du cimetière romain
[musique]